so I sort of don't even know how to
introduce this first story today except
I guess to just start with the facts a
photographer caught a picture of Donald
Trump's handwritten notes that he had
made right after he finished giving just
to completely off the rails unhinged
press conference on Monday and in the
handwritten notes which were
photographed Trump had the terrorist
group Al Qaeda written as Al CAI da all
one word more like a superfood berry of
some kind than the terrorist group and
right away when the world expressed
concern that the guys clueless the usual
defenders came out of the woodwork and
said listen just because you can't spell
doesn't mean you can't think he could be
incorrectly spelling really good ideas
it's ablest to criticize the fact that
he seems unable to spell which is sort
of extra funny because when you hear
from people who seem to have no
concerned about disabled rights start to
say you're being mean to trump in an
ableist way because the guy can't spell
that's weird
and it's also weird because it implies
that Trump has some kind of cognitive
disability which those same people have
to date denied is the case but this has
become popular recently I saw some
people recently explaining or attempting
to explain you know when you go online
and someone says your instead of you
apostrophe re it's totally irrelevant
whether they spelled something correctly
or whether they use the right version of
your or your they might just process
information differently they could still
have really good ideas these are still
people who we should be turning to when
it comes to political ideas and how the
country should be organized or whatever
there's no connection between their
spelling and grammar and anything else
the thing is this is not the case for
Donald Trump okay there are certainly
people that we could identify and say
hey you know what they have dyslexia and
here's how this is reflected but it
really doesn't seem to influence their
ability to think it's no indication of
the fact that they are limited or
ignorant or whatever else this is not
some mere isolated spelling mistake with
Donald Trump the press conference itself
off-the-rails the ideas that Trump
espouses are off the rails he has
demonstrated himself to be ignorant to
foreign and domestic policy and economic
policy and and and so many other things
and it turns out that he also doesn't
seem to know that al Qaeda al
- QA EDA is not spelled al CAI da this
is Red Alert insanity for a President of
the United States now I thought it was
actually a joke when I saw this I
thought that this was some kind of
Photoshop thing I I truly didn't believe
that Donald Trump had written down what
looks like Al sayyida on a piece of
paper as his notes but it is real and
this is the press conference in which
Donald Trump said that for ethnically
minority Congress women should go back
to where they originally came from their
original countries for which he was
ridiculed worldwide and this is all made
much worse when you realized that Donald
Trump's absurd and erratic comments
weren't actually off-the-cuff
we often say Trump should really stick
to his notes or the script or the
teleprompter that he criticized Barack
Obama for using but now relies on
himself because if he strays from it if
he goes off the cuff he goes off the
rails
he had these ideas in his notes not only
Al sayyida but also stuff about these
people and socialism and whatever else
and I hate to bring this up again only
because it's so obsessing to imagine
that this is what's going on obviously
this is renewing fears and concerns
about dementia or cognitive decline in
Donald Trump yeah Trump might just be a
bad speller in addition to being
completely ignorant and narcissistic and
xenophobic and racist and a sexual
predator but once again we do have to
confront the possibility that there's
cognitive decline here and every new
glimpse we get into the mind of Donald
Trump is only increasing the concerns
that this is more than just a guy who
can't spell and has bad ideas this is a
story about winning the birth lottery
okay Trump is a guy who if he were not
the son of a millionaire who gave Trump
a small loan of a million bucks to start
a real estate business
would be the guy ranting about Jesus on
the subway platform okay
were it not for being the CEO his entire
life like if Trump actually had to work
somewhere like a normal employee his
personality combined with his ignorance
would make him unable to hold the job in
any other country by the way Trump would
only be a billionaire real estate dude
he would not have become president of
the United States here in the United
States we have the sort of special
privilege as some might call it and I'm
using that term sarcastically we have
the special privilege of having 60
million people who thought this was a
good idea when they voted back in
November of 2016 or at least a better
idea than Hillary Clinton so this is a
combination this is a rare combination
that we have of someone who to go back
to the beginning of the story yes can't
spell and is a narcissist xenophobic
ignorant whatever who also only even had
the possibility of running for president
because of winning the birth lottery in
the United States and had the benefit of
tens of millions of ignorant people in
the United States who thought it was a
good idea to vote for him it really
takes you know we talked about the
multiverse theories multiverse
hypotheses about you can imagine that
there are an infinite number of
additional universes in which everything
is possible where you are king of the
United States and whatever else we seem
to be in one of those wacky scenarios
where the stars have aligned so to speak
and Donald Trump has been able to become
President of the United States and it's
bad I'm glad that foreign leaders are
finally saying the extent to which it's
bad and they recognize it's bad now we
just have to make the right decision in
November of 2020 today's program brought
to you in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman Blinky's is a great service that
I use all the time what they do is they
take thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink as' I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's
Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book of BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listened to on blinka
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I'm putting a link in the
video description and after the free
trial if you'd like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa que ma n